[Musique]
regardes tu as vu ce n'est pas un match
de foot mais tous les mômes du quartier
tourne autour il y en a trois différents
ils ont commencé à peindre sur le port
aussi quelque chose se prépare
[Musique]
je peux voir le responsable défense
d'entrée
amine des lots la bataille du carnaval a
commencé quatre chantiers au total dans
quatre quartiers et concurrents
[Musique]
l'an dernier ces mondes se sait qui a
gagné les voici au travail avec leur
général en chef valdir 30 en dix mois si
on le peut en doré ce sera joli
oui je pense c'est pas trop compliqué
cette année notre thème c'est la
créativité en eau du char on va mettre
un cerveau géant parce que c'est ça
qu'on utilise tous pour être créatif
c'est du cerveau des neurones que sont
sortis les idées les plus brillantes du
monde comme le téléphone
l'ipad n'est pas encore posée ou encore
la fresques de michel-ange dans la
chapelle sixtine et c'est du cerveau de
valve dire que sont sortis ces figures
monumentales
[Musique]
plus qu'une semaine avant le jour j pour
battre les autres équipes valdir a une
arme secrète un atout maître qu'il est
allé recruter en dehors du quartier
[Musique]
ça va ma belle regarde je t'ai apporté
ton diadème josi est une ancienne miss
cap vert elle sera la reine de manque ce
segment
tu veux les mettre comment tes cheveux
je vais les attachés en arrière ensuite
on mettra des extensions bouclés qui
arrivent ont jusqu'ici ce sera
magnifique magnifique
[Musique]
les concurrents de monde se serre
donnerait cher pour connaître cette
adresse
salut a tous bonjour madame dimanche va
le dire le capitaine demande sauce aigre
a aussi dessiné les 1800 costume du
définit notamment le plus attendu de
tous celui de la reine tu es dedans
mettez moi je me lève tes mains
attention ça lui descend son bustier son
but y est descendu je vais couper un peu
la robe attends attends attends c'est
une opération très délicate
c'est bon allez-y ça y est tu vends tué
plus d'un le jour du carnaval
j'espère bien
sincère monde se serre est un quartier
populaire
il y à plus de 1000 participants à cette
répétition
j'en ai les jambes qui tremblent mais
quelle énergie un fils c'est exactement
ce que j'espérais
[Musique]
la reine n'avait pas encore été présenté
à son peuple ni son roi que voici
parent
maintenant nous allons appeler notre
reine du carnaval 2015 jocelyne rochât
on l'applaudît
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je ne danse pas je garde l'énergie
pour le travail mais le jour du défilé
oui on dansera le patron à s'éclipser
il a d'autres soucis en tête un imprévu
qui pourrait tout gâcher pour l'heure la
chorégraphie ça juste avec des danseurs
de 7 à 77 ans tous seront du défilé
[Musique]
ça y est je suis officiellement la reine
demande sociale c'est une grande fierté
c'est une responsabilité important
d'avoir tous ces gens qui me soutiennent
les enfants par exemple
merci à tous
[Musique]
la pluie en cette saison c'est rarissime
et c'est ça qui inquiétait valdir hier
soir regarde il faut faire attention à
la bâche il faut la tourner pour que ça
n'abîme pas la statue tu as compris on
va tourner la pièce comme ceux ci on est
à trois jours du carnaval alors on n'a
vraiment pas le temps de fabriquer des
pièces comme celle doit découvrir le
vent aussi peu les abîmer attention
métal ça peut déchirer la bâche vas-y
vas-y attrape le vite vite
vas-y c'est un défi c'est préoccupant
très préoccupant quand on voit cette
pluie qui met en danger tout notre
travail
le lendemain matin inventaire des dégâts
la télé tout ça c'est du bois et du
plâtre ça peut s'abîmer
il ya de l'eau qui s'est infiltrée on va
devoir réparer
on ne peut pas laisser ça craint c'est
un travail qu'on a déjà fait il va
falloir leur faire on va rattraper ça
moi je vous le dire s'il faut on
travaillera toute la nuit
allez on y retourne on va travailler à
l'atelier reviendra dehors quand tout
sera sec marc palmarolle ça ok
[Musique]
les dieux du carnaval on faire revenir
le soleil sur mines des lots
[Musique]
josy continue sa préparation avec
marianne à l'arel de l'an dernier c'est
un moment super fatigant je veux pas me
mettre la pression je vais être sincère
avec toi je sais je suis en train de
vivre la même chose en ce moment c'est
vraiment fatiguant
dis-moi comment tu as vécu ça ça c'était
une drôle d'aventuré
est-ce que tu as eu peur de tomber du
chat je peux te dire qu'à ce moment là
les pompiers m'aider à monter sur le
char pass vip la tribe temps comme
chaque mois est debout je voyais des
hommes qui accouraient est en fait ben
tout simplement il regardait sous ma
robe
sérieux ça tarde à mettre une jolie
culotte
ça me fait peur ce que tu viens de me
dire je vais portait un legging sont à
rob la reine les belles allées
magnifique josy et voilà la très jolie
sourire je pense que ce sera j'espère
qu'elle va gagner
elle va gagner en tant que reine le chi
dieuleveux oui oui si tu le veux j'en
suis sûr
[Musique]
demain josy sera au centre de tous les
regards
[Musique]
la reine se retire pour la soirée
hammond ce segment certains n'auront pas
la chance de dormir
c'est comme un studio de cinéma façon de
cap vert s'était évanoui dans la colle
et les blagues ça fait du bien
sinon on n'y arriverai pas cap vert ça
veut dire no stress cette année les
chars sont équipés de moteur premier
test
lentement mais sûrement
ça avance
[Musique]
à l'atelier aussi une nuit blanche
s'annonce
[Musique]
jetons
tout pour la victoire les quatre
quartiers en lice vont passer une nuit
de fièvre
le lendemain les chars demande sauce
aigre tarder à sortir
regarde le mec il est encore en train de
24 ans
[Musique]
c'est qu'il manque encore quelques
ajustements
tiens tiens apprend prend la gélule fois
que ça irait si on accélère pas ses
morts allez on y va on y va
jusqu'à la dernière seconde de la
dernière minute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la cavalcade on a juste oublié un
petit détail ce char est trop grand
il savait pas qu'on aurait cette
difficulté a déclaré on va vite devoir
trouver une solution
il faut que le chat recul pour pouvoir
passer et que les gars puissent tirer
l'arbre en arrière à les tirer
allez-y allez-y ça va passer
l'arbre fini par céder le passage
tout est bien qui commence bien le
défilé est dans deux heures les chars
seront au rendez vous
et où en sont les stars de monde se sert
leroy prend la couronne
[Musique]
sa reine a moins de chance c'est pas
confortable sa tombe est le métal me
gêne josy et eu trop nerveuse ce matin
tu l'avais essayé mais là je suis
coiffée ça fait pas pareil c'est normal
d'être nerveuse tout doit être parfait
la mort fait mais bon sur le char ça
devrait aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais